tell us a little bit about uh the
genesis of this project i know that it's
uh had a circus route to this screen
tonight
we're good friends with the writers
andrew cohen and brendan o'brien we've
known them
for years uh andrew used to work for
judd uh in like 2004
and brendan uh worked for our producer
at the time uh shauna robertson
and we became friends with them and were
friends with them ever since and then
basically uh around two years ago i'm
gonna say they uh came to us and pitched
us
the idea of like uh
uh me and uh my family living next to a
fraternity
and from the beginning it was me and zac
efron like in their
uh pitch like when they uh first had the
idea and then we pitched it to zach
and he really liked the idea and so we
were both like attached and then we went
out and pitched it to all the studios
and uh universal uh ended up buying it
and then uh we got nick to direct it
it changed quite a lot as far as the
dynamics of the story um you guys
it's uh
reshape it is that correct yeah pre-nick
it was about seth and two of his buddies
uh guys and they kind of had a war with
the frat and then we realized that it
might be better to have the female
character kind of be a larger character
uh and have it be a 50 50 story with her
in set my wife gets really mad at any
noise
so i thought i thought the wife
character would be probably get involved
and i remember you said his buddies
don't own the house they own the house
that's great and then as far as bringing
the family into it uh
was there any times where you guys went
up to a point and said well we can't do
this or that since there's a baby like i
was glad to see that there wasn't a uh
um
you know a uh uh airbag in the baby crib
it was like a turning point right you
know we filmed that with tons of babies
it didn't go well
we just didn't use it
you don't like baby danger well you know
you go to the edge and you turn back
yeah that's the sequel to this name for
a movie yeah baby baby danger
it's called it was called baby's day out
actually yeah it was uh yeah we go very
far when we film stuff much further than
even what you've seen here tonight um
and then
uh we kind of scale it it's kind of an
addition by subtraction i would say uh
we we screen it for audiences and we see
what gets laughs and what doesn't
um
and uh yeah and we kind of listen to
what to what the kids enjoy basically um
and uh yeah we kind of
we record the laughter and we videotape
them and we really uh we really we
really listen to it i mean it's hard to
justify keeping it a joke even if we
love it if no one in the test screenings
laughs at it and so yeah we
we learn a lot from that there was uh
the the condom was made of like out of
like a fruit roll-up material
and um in the first screen what the baby
actually did is all babies do is baby
grabbed it put the condom in it in her
mouth made an adorable face like
that kind of phase much cuter than my
face doing it and chewed on it for a
while
and uh in the first cut there was 30
seconds of baby chewing on a condom
and the audience rejected it
they weren't into that so
that's where you get addition by
subtraction but less less is more
sometimes when it comes to condoms and
babies mouths
that's a good motto uh in general uh
that's interesting uh it's in sit field
frankly in the pitch it was kind of like
seth's the good guy and zack's the bad
guy but i think zach really had a point
of view and wanting his character to be
someone who was you know who as he kept
saying other fraternity guys would
really like and understand and and then
as we cast dave franco and gerard and
christians plus it became super clear
that like they had a whole story and
thing that thing of their own
and i think as we were making the movie
we just
stayed true to that it's like they're
kids trying to have a good time you know
doing stupid stuff and mac and kelly
have their story and they you know sort
of they come into conflict with one
another but it's not like
one is book good and one is bad really
so
they're both just dumb
everyone's dumb yeah it's the unifying
flattening factory comedy it's pretty
simple i mean
if you're not i mean
not everyone does it i mean it's
definitely a discipline um to
you know at times just regard your own
taste for what's hopeful hopefully like
the greater good of the movie you know
um
and
there's probably a few jokes in there
that don't get like the 10 out of 10
laugh that you would hope for but we
really like them so they're still there
um but uh but yeah we try i mean no i
mean
it's it's it's not that hard because
there's nothing worse than sitting in a
movie theater full of people and have
them not laugh at something that you
think is funny so
um it's like once you make a few movies
you just start to like really
wait for those big giant laughs and like
not like soon just like little laughs
don't cut it anymore you want to get
like those explosive laughs like the
only way to achieve
that at the frequency that you would
want it to happen is
to screen the movie a lot and really
listen to the people basically and
um again i think like what you lose in
the moment maybe by cutting a joke you
like you gain
overall by having a movie that like as
you sit through it a thousand times
plays as well as you would hope you know
yeah there's something funny that
happens too just psychologically people
remember their favorite jokes as getting
laughs like usually which means the joke
you wrote and so and when you record the
last it makes everyone really honest
because people like that joke gotta
laugh and i mean i include myself with
that joke gotta laugh and then like no
it didn't and you just play the thing
yeah it's a good like argument like it
solves the ends of the argument yeah it
does there's also a real sense that uh
this movie is made by people that love
movies i mean you can see
uh whether it's the christian bale
michael keaton thing that we were
talking about that i just loved
because that is so of
movie fandom like by generation but uh
but you guys feel like there's a lot of
uh like shining and other things popping
up animal house obviously and stuff like
that uh is that something that just kind
of bubbles up through
who everybody is or is it very kind of
focused it's all about not reading books
the more you watch stuff and don't read
stuff you get these pop culture
references i actually watched a great
thing on youtube explaining that seth is
only famous because of his excellent
knowledge of pop culture references and
it showed like a montage of it all and
it's it's really true though he
knows what people are watching and he
references it like oh that's like tony
soprano doing this all that and like
it's just what people talk about people
don't talk about anna karenina quite as
much as reality television as sad as
that might be and it just people connect
to it so i think just all of us being
kind of normal schmucks helps a lot it's
true fantastic yeah it's like woody
allen if he was stupid